think about your family for just one
second think about whether it was your
parents that came here whether you're
first generation or whether it was your
great-grandparents or whether your great
great great great grandparents were
Founders think about your family why did
they come here they came here for the
opportunity for Freedom everyone comes
here because it's still better here than
pretty much anywhere else it's why AOC
does not leave it's why ilhan Omar does
not leave and yet they have decided with
the Biden Administration to import all
the ideas that our ancestors fled from
we can stop it today we truly can do you
remember
the America that I'm talking about I
think you should you probably do even
though they make it very hard to
remember but it was good it was good and
decent and just and uh well Ronald
Reagan do a little something about that
let our friends
and those who may wish us ill take notes
the United States has an obligation to
its citizens and to the people of the
world
never to let those who would destroy
freedom dictate the future course of
Life on this planet
[Applause]
yes how about that